A, quote,
act of piracy on the Black Sea,
according to the government of Ukraine.
A Russian battleship fired warning shots
at an empty Turkish cargo ship on Sunday
and then sent a helicopter full
of Russian servicemen
to the Turkish vessel
and questioned
the Turkish captain for an hour.
Russia claims
that the ship did not respond
to an inspection request while on land.
Russian shelling hit the southern
region of her zone.
Buildings and families torn apart.
A mom and dad
their 12 year
old boy and a just over
three week
old baby girl who lived in this house
did not survive.
In response,
Ukrainian President
Volodymyr Zelensky
has vowed, quote, completely fair
retaliation against Russia.
Meanwhile, the U.S.
just announced
a new
$200 million round of military
aid for Ukraine, which includes
more artillery,
air defense, munitions
and mine clearing equipment.
That last piece especially vital
as Ukraine's defense minister declares
Ukraine is now the most heavily
mined country in the world.
CNN's Nick Paton Walsh
got exclusive access to a team
that finds those deadly explosives on
the front lines.
The fires still smolder, but
dusk moving to the very front
of Ukraine's counteroffensive.
Nic Robertson
to
Moscow.
There was intense bombardment
around this area
and now the sun is setting.
There's the occasional
round being fired
for most of it seems to be
towards Russian positions.
All right.
We're here to learn of a new tactic
that may help Ukraine overcome
one of the hardest obstacles
here, minefields
Shellfire is a constant overhead.
The drone
unit used daylight
to help direct artillery fire
You see them coming shortly.
So they're using this to correct
the next shell that's fired
And now they must keep hidden
combat
on this.
Russell, to seal the Senate Chinook
or the artillery
task team in the matter will put you up.
There's still the basic problem
that it's trench warfare and minefields
and by definition makes the going slow
But as the sky darkens and
the air cools here,
an advantage has emerged.
One of their drones is equipped
with a thermal camera.
And they've noticed out
in the wide cratered fields,
about four kilometers away,
where the Russians hide something new.
Some of these
white dots are Russian landmines.
They retain the heat of the summer sun
as the earth around them cools.
The contrast is greatest at dusk.
Or dawn, experts say.
So they seem to glow.
The unit told us they use special charges
to blow up the mines.
It's not a precise science,
but a huge help
in seeing an invisible enemy.
But politically philosophical,
no matter somebody's true, you shouldn't
the families of those
three first Oscar
are stuck in these
minutes of violence
and will get the money automatic
should they out
encircled by mines.
Don't try to tell them
that counteroffensive
could be faster than
when I
learned to dig down a lot
because they didn't
And so contrasting
that is the capital structure
to give us much to talk about.
I don't have to go into that to
you know, it's took
a lot of extensive opportunities.
No mistake.
There's little time to reflect, though.
Guys from not come, go, go, go.
There's a Russian helicopter
is spotted coming right at them.
We take cover for it to pass.
This is the kind of threat
they endure every day.
Well, just one piece of information
concerning the running for cover
and then we leave
hours after we left.
We're told
that trench network
came under heavy Russian attack,
which they repelled.
But the grind is constant
and respite left.
And any advantage, no matter how small,
urgently welcome
Jake, it's important to remember
when you look at that
use of essentially
relatively low technology
to try and confront
an extraordinary enemy
there, that volume of landmines
that we often at times,
I think
imagine the Western equipment
given to the Ukrainian military
generously at times
has sort of
been enough
is kind of answer the question of
do they have the tools they need to do
the job here?
They are still up
against the Russian military
that have
quite a lot of sophisticated equipment
on their sides.
They certainly feel it there
on those front lines.
And day by day,
they are doing anything they possibly can
to inch forwards that you saw there
in those thermal images.
Just how many landmines
there are in one small field?
That's what they're up against.
That is what is taking the limbs
of their colleagues and friends
every day.
And that is what they're now using.
Those heat cameras
to try and find a way around
ingenuity every day,
but still a constant grind Jake.
More great reporting
from Nick Paton Walsh
in the Dnipro, Ukraine.
Thank you so much.